live dancing the live dance they can see
me dancing but they can't see you
dancing in fact I work everybody another
YouTube hang out super excited to be
here I'm with my friend Lindsey from the
frugal crafter a fellow youtuber and we
met through Tim Schmoyer 'he's youtube
collaboration thing that we had going on
and she had a lot of great advice and I
thought it'd be great to introduce you
to her and share some of her
entrepreneur wisdom and so welcome
aboard Lindsey hi thanks for having me
for people who aren't familiar with your
channel maybe just give a quick
introduction to what you're all about I
linked it up in the description but for
people you know to be able to hear it
from you what are you all about I'm all
about sharing my love of arts and crafts
with everybody I think that you can
create no matter what your budget is no
matter where you live it's all about
being resourceful and not about your
resources so I just love to spread the
joy of creating I think it makes
everybody's lives um more happy and
enjoyable and worthwhile if they take a
little time to make something every day
and I just want to show people different
ways they can do that without spending
tons of money and so I can get that
perfume in out of life it's a very human
thing to do to want to make something
and create were the only creatures that
do that so I just want to kind of help
spread the joy and get people inspired I
love it so my audience is entrepreneurs
and one of the message did I say over
and over and over again it's not about
how many resources you have is about how
resourceful you are so I love that you
open with that because that I think
immediately resonates I don't really
know so part of having you on was also
knowing like your the background the
story when you've been doing YouTube for
think six years what got you started and
wanting to create your channel well I
was a teacher an art teacher and I had
my own studio and I was an art director
at a nonprofit organization and i just
love teaching i loved seeing the joy in
people's faces i loved it when I was
teaching a class to senior citizens and
they said I just forgot all my worries i
have a big operation tomorrow or I'm
waiting to get test results back
I just completely forgot about that for
the last two hours painting with you and
I just thought that was so powerful and
if you can take away some of these
worries for a little bit every day and
give them something to look forward to
then it's a huge gift and all those
little impacts can make a big impact so
when I when I had my first child I was
able to bring him to work with me I had
somebody sit with him in my studio at a
very large studio and but then I got
pregnant with twins and I realized that
trying to manage three little children
because my son wasn't even two yet in my
studio which was on the second floor in
a downtown building so there's no
parking I was just like I can't do it
all at once so I closed my studio and I
started blogging and I really missed
that connection of teaching um so just
kind of on a whim I decided I would try
youtube and see if I could teach people
like card making and jewelry making and
different techniques like that on the
internet and I just had a little point
and shoot camera that I took snapshots
with that had a horrible microphone but
it got me a start and I did like
probably 200 videos on that thing and
there was a community there you know
other people found a need for this and
enjoyed it and so I eventually got a
real camera and just kept making videos
because it you know it reached out it
touched people they enjoyed it I made
friends and it was a way for me to
continue teaching while I stayed home
and cared for my children cool and now
you have how many subscribers you have
two hundred thousand-plus almost 300,000
I think it's about 240,000 right around
there forty thousand so so you're
starting off yeah you've got this camera
you know at the beginning you're not
getting a lot of traction you're not
getting a lot of comments of views and
maybe you were I mean ever seen my story
it wasn't even in my like landscape to
even think about like I'm going to be
famous I'm going to make this a career
it was I want to share and my blog had
been pretty popular and I embedded all
my videos in my blog so it was a chance
for the people that have been following
my blog to kind of you know put a voice
to the in the face to the projects so it
didn't even I didn't even know I don't
know what my subscriber numbers were for
the first couple years I think
I I cared about sharing I love seeing
the comments it was just a just very fun
positive experience I I never even
thought it would be a way to earn a
living it was just kind of something I
did on the side for fun you know it was
you know I was even on my landscape to
worry about how many people were
watching or how many subscribers i had
interesting when i had my channel well
when i started my channel i still have
my channel i did a lot of Q&A from
people because i would spend 30 40
minutes responding to one person's email
and I thought this is just so much
easier to do in a video and I'll put it
live just to share with that person and
if anybody else wants to watch it that's
cool too position we neither of us had
this goal to be like this huge youtuber
and now it's going to take it over it's
become our business okay so the topic of
of staying inspired and and keeping your
passion for your business kind of walk
me through the you've been around for
six years doing this what are the phases
that you had like at the beginning being
inspired having passion then like maybe
bumps or roadblocks that you had that
may be kind of held you back made you
doubt yourself and how you broke through
them because i think that journey could
be really inspiring for others who are
on their path in entrepreneurship sure
okay so like like you said evan neither
of us um really started YouTube to
become a youtuber or make it our
business so when I first went from
closing my studio to being at home with
my children I knew I wanted to work from
home so i thought the the logical step
would be to get my work in magazines and
so i told myself i'd try it for a year
I'd at least submit a couple things
every month for one year and see you
know if anything happened if nothing
happened that I just didn't have the
chops for it and I would move on but I
would I made myself do it for a year so
every month I would send in a few
scrapbook layouts cards jewelry designs
and it took 11 months and something
finally got picked up for bead trends
magazine and then that gave me a lil
encouragement and I was still blogging
all the while just because I figured it
would help my writing and you know the
more I could get myself out there the
more chances that somebody might come to
me and you know offer me a spot in a
magazine or
thing and then as I and then after that
first thing got published more things
got got published in magazines and then
I started to realize I kind of started
to see kind of the truth behind the lens
there where there really wasn't the
money in publishing and from doing all
this work and I'm putting in all this
effort to give to magazines for very
little reward a lot a lot of magazines I
didn't realize this when I started but a
lot of magazines do not pay for their
content they just expect you to send it
to him for the glory of being in a
magazine so I thought well if I'm going
to give my work for free and they're
gonna sell the magazine and people have
to pay to see it why don't I just put it
for free on the internet and reach the
more the most people that I can and kind
of cut out the middleman if I'm not
going to make any money doing it this
way doing it the you know um the logical
way or the way that's already been done
I'm going to do it this new way and and
it proved to be quite successful and
then and I thought well why not you tube
and then it was probably um probably a
year year and a half after started my
channel I got approached by a sponsor a
paper company that asked me if they
could sponsor some videos and I never
even thought about that being a like a
stream of income so I thought about it
then I'm and he asked my husband about
it he said well you know if you're you
could try it and if your audience really
is turned off by that then you don't
have to do it but you know what's the
harm and they're actually still a
sponsor today it's paper Mart for
anybody that follows my my channel
they're fantastic company oh how long
have they been with you since 2012 so
more years yeah um doing weekly weekly
videos um and so that really kind of
opened my my mind that wow I have some
influence there um this could turn into
something where I could continue to
offer more free videos because at that
point I was doing for videos a month it
wasn't a lot so then when I got that
sponsorship i started doing eight videos
month because i didn't i felt an
obligation to my community to still do
what i was doing and I don't know it
maybe it's silly but I felt like kind of
like obligation I didn't want my
editorial content controlled I wanted to
make sure i was still giving them the
stuff that they wanted to see and this
was like kind of a bonus episode and
then since money was rolling in I could
put more time in effort into my channel
so i can make more videos and then you
know more sponsors came
you mean more money came in that I could
spend more time doing videos so it was
kind of like feeding the Beast um and at
that point I still wasn't monetizing my
videos as far as you too bad since I was
just you know I'm like well you know
that that's not gonna pay anything I
hold you know I think I tried to
monetize one video it paid like 25 cents
in a month in life that's not what many
people sit through ads for that so you
know and so but the sponsors kept
feeding the Beast I was able to do more
and more videos and that's kind of what
kind of motivated me to grow the channel
because I could afford to put time into
it I wasn't feeling like I was being
selfish and pouring all kinds of time
into this project that was just for me
that was in bringing an income in for my
family because I also did picture
framing and I did graphic design and you
know a few artsy ob's to contribute um
and now it's to the point where my
youtube channel fuels my business mostly
I mean I do i do teach workshops and
classes and stuff but the youtube
channel is really the bread and butter
of the business and it's you know it's
because of sponsorships and i think
people think of sponsorships is kind of
like the big evil side of YouTube but it
really it pays the bill so people can
focus more into their channel um so
anyway so that's that's how that kind of
came to be and I haven't really had too
many um too many roadblocks because I
was never in doing videos for the money
I was doing it because I was passionate
about it and I was just thrilled when I
was making some money so I could put
more time into it um I think when people
flip that switch to monetize your videos
when they first start a channel and they
look at how little money coming in and
they look at the analytics daily I think
that's very defeating and I think if
people can take kind of not even put
that into the equation focus on sharing
what you're passionate about and having
fun you're going to get you're going to
go so much further so much faster and
you're not going to give up because
you're not going to be you know defeated
by the numbers you're going to you're
going to concentrate how you feel and
how you're making your community feel as
opposed to looking at those hard numbers
saying oh I made a dollar fifty to this
month I guess this isn't gonna you know
be a career you know just I know right
take me back to the you said you you
gave yourself a year to get the
magazines you want to get covered and
you know you're you've got kids at home
now you're trying to make this something
work
and you it's 11 months until you get the
first nibble how do you keep going
because a lot of a lot of people want to
start something up there like okay I
gave it three weeks it didn't work or I
gave it two months or three months and
another month and it's like nothing has
happened I keep doing the same thing
over and over and over again is like 11
months until you got your first nibble
how do you keep going through that like
in 110 you got to be frustrated that
nothing is happening how did you get up
the next day and then contact another
magazine what was going through your
head well I was raised by entrepreneurs
so I know the struggle I know that it
takes most businesses three years before
they turn a profit I was in it for the
long haul I just I knew realistically
what it was going to take it was
frustrating but I told myself I was
going to do it for a year and I do not
back out on what i tell myself I'm going
to do I told myself a year for a reason
I knew it was highly competitive I knew
there were millions of stay-at-home moms
are trying to get their scrapbook pages
published in their cards published I
knew there was tough competition and I
knew I had no contacts so I knew I was
behind the eight ball and it was going
to take time and you know I was willing
to put in a year so that's basically
what it comes down to I remember my dad
he was a contractor then he opened up a
hardware store and he was putting up
this humongous warehouse where he where
you know the lumber would be stored and
it was just this massive building and he
put it up and it came down he put it up
a second time and it came down and I
thought that would break him he put it
up again it was like I could just see
you like that was like I could just see
him out on the edge but he put it up
again and that sucker stayed up and his
businesses you know as robust as it's
ever been because he didn't give up when
that building came down the second time
you know he stuck with it and when you
have role models like that I think it's
really powerful you know what I've had
to go through is nothing compared to
what my parents have gone through as far
as building their business you know I'm
on easy street when I think about it I
mean I'm making art every day if I make
it harder every day and I can pay the
bills then
you know there's really not much to be
frustrated with in life so you know I
just think that's what it was for me I'm
seeing that example was like hey I
didn't have a building fall down three
times i can keep getting up and doing it
you know yeah that's an awesome
perspective and i think uh it'd be great
for a lot of people that go through that
i mean i know it sucks but I so many
people set a goal for the year right
like I'm going to give myself a year to
do this how many new year's resolutions
to people make and then you know two
weeks in they quit so to actually follow
through on when you said like wit you
think it just comes from your parents
and the role models the stubbornness
like stick to it witness I'm going to
make this happen well I think part of it
but I also set specific goals like it's
like every month i'm sending
you
alright guys I don't know what's going
on I was really enjoying her story hi
you go we got her back hey sorry about
that but I I'd left a note for my son he
came in I said do not get on the
internet pretty sure he came home and
went on the internet so it kind of
diminished the bandwidth but but we're
back now so hopefully he realized i left
a note but i don't know where i was when
it cut off uh you were so we're talking
about new years resolutions not sticking
people don't stick with it for a year
you were saying you had something really
specific a goal that you were really on
and wasn't just some like non-tangible
thing but it's really specific and then
we lost you oh ok yeah so um so
basically I told myself I was giving it
a year and I had specific like a
specific routine I was gonna follow like
every Monday I am emailing you know five
magazines I'm taking or I'm taking all
the artwork I made during the week and
it's i'm emailing it out to all my
contacts and and i did i would take like
one layout and i would email at five
magazines because at first i would take
one layout and wait hear back from
another magazine but i'd never hear back
they wouldn't even say no thank you i
mean that's how saturated it was they
couldn't even reply saying no thanks I
don't think half of them got seen so
knowing the reality that probably half
of what you're sending out isn't even
getting in front of a pair of eyeballs
was really really made me push harder
and make sure that i was putting that
frequency out because i know if an
editor saw my name in their inbox once a
week they would say this girl is not
giving up let's take a look you know
they would remember the name so i really
think that success in anything comes
down to persistence and inconsistency
then then talent even I mean if you can
be persistent you have much better shot
of getting something happen for you I
think is a great story I don't think
enough entrepreneur stick with it long
enough and and I don't know that you
like I think you give yourself a ton of
credit for it and you and maybe your
parents best working from because to do
it for 11 months you know ten and a half
months and not get any results most
people would would quit way
way sooner and so it's a it's a I love
it it's a nice inspirational story no
thanks so i told myself a year right
when i started so it's like well if i
give up at ten months and it and on the
eleventh month that would have gotten
something published I mean that I would
never know I would be doing nothing
right now I would probably have just one
well I don't have the have what it takes
i might as well you know i don't know do
something else because this you know you
have to stick to you have to set a goal
you have to stick to it but if you make
a specific plan on how you're going to
attack it it really helps but yeah i
think a lot of people give up before
they they have a chance to succeed yeah
i love i love to learn a little bit more
about your process because i think you
could really help the people watching
because i think people understand the
importance of setting goals and a lot of
people do set goals and they set
specific goals some of them may have a
plan to follow up with or not or maybe
not too specific enough but then they
still quit you know they still don't go
ten and a half months before they get a
response and they're going to cut out so
if you think it just comes down to the
values you got from your parents or was
there something else that you did that
really helped you are you just the kind
of person who once you set your mind to
sell plane i'm gonna have it's gonna
happen no matter what what do you think
well i think um I think that's part of
it once I set my mind to something it's
going to happen um I heard a quote once
and it said the the reasonable man
something that the reasonable man will
do what the world tells them to and the
the unreasonable man will change the
world to what he wants or something like
that so I've always been a little
unreasonable you know I've always kind
of gone against the flow even though I'm
always telling my kids go with the flow
like she's your go with the flow you
know I always kind of went against the
flow but um you know and not everybody's
cut out to be an entrepreneur or even
work for themselves you know it's not in
everybody's it's not best for everybody
some people won't need the routine of it
takes a lot of discipline I guess is
what I'm trying to say and some people
need the routine of going to a job and
and having their day laid out for them
and having expectations that other
people hold them accountable to and when
you're working for yourself or an
entrepreneur you have to hold yourself
to your to your schedule you have to be
self-disciplined because
as otherwise you could sit around all
day and watch Netflix and crochet and
not actually get a pattern written or a
video done or patterns into a magazine
or anything like that so I think that a
lot of people lack the discipline unless
somebody else is telling them because
they don't have the self I love it's
like self respect because I know a lot
of people won't hold themselves
accountable but if I if you know you
talked to this person said hey could you
do this for me they do it for you but
they wouldn't they can't tell themselves
to do something for some reason they
can't hold themselves accountable for
themselves but if somebody else asks
them to they'll do it I don't know what
that is if it's a self confidence thing
um or or what but um so not everybody is
best suited to be an entrepreneur I
think you have to be able to be
disciplined and you know force yourself
through your day even if you don't feel
like it you know even if you feel like
you'd rather have a nap you have to get
up and you have to do work because you
know you're not getting a paid vacation
you're not getting you know if that work
doesn't it done you don't get paid for
it if nobody else is going to do it for
you I guess um so I think a lot of
people maybe don't understand that's
like I mean when I get up I have a
routine even though I don't go to a job
I self a routine routine every day I get
up I make my coffee now check my email
and I get computer work done like like
right there um kind of first hour and a
half or so and then I exercise and then
hop in the shower put my face on and
then I'll do any filming or any stuff
that takes kind of that that energy the
high energy stuff and then then like
I'll make a cup of tea and I'll sit down
and I'll edit they'll go into like a
low-energy mode so it's like I know when
my high energy time is so I just kind of
stick to that schedule even though it's
a different project and doing every day
and it's different you know issues and
dealing with a computer i'm launching a
class this week so you know that's been
very I've been doing a lot of the
computer this week but I still keep
myself to a schedule so that I don't
just wander off aimlessly and spend
three hours on Pinterest because I can
definitely do that if I'm not careful I
like the comment about managing your
energy people just manage their time but
managing energy super super important so
now when you are creative when you have
high energy it's great and I mean that
speaks to your success too cool let's
get to the questions we got some people
writing in xenos writing in as
both create video content do you ever
feel like you want to make different
kinds of videos if so how do you do that
without losing your current viewer base
um well I think probably Evan and I both
have the same very similar situation
since my channel is started off as like
card making and crafting and then I I
moved over to doing more fine art um I
actually I have different programming on
different days so like once we got to a
pastel tutorial do a watercolor tutorial
I do a card making tutorial might do a
jewelry or scrapbooking tutorial so
there's a different video every day but
not everybody in my audience is going to
like everything so if you joined because
you enjoy card making you'll probably
watch a card making stamping and
scrapbooking videos but you might not
watch the painting videos unless you're
interested in a certain technique to
apply to your other crafts um they'll be
people there that subscribe because they
like pastel videos they might watch the
pastel and the oil painting you know so
it's kind of like and you mentioned it
to before Evan about your your channel
being a channel not a show you know
people can tune in for different things
they're not going to like everything but
if you add something to your lineup
without taking something else away I
think you can do it very successfully so
if you had a you know if you had like a
woodworking channel and you wanted to do
like I don't know maybe like a you know
wood finishing or something something
that's along those lines as long as it's
not like you know out and left field
like cooking or something that's totally
crazy I think you can go ahead and and
put it on there I think having multiple
channels can really divide your
attention and divide your energy and
ultimately make it very overwhelming to
to try to stay on top of everything yeah
I think your business should always be a
reflection of who you are I think though
the work that you do if you have a job
like the work that you do should always
be a reflection of who you are and what
you're curious about and your business
should change as you change as a human
being and so if you look at my channel
it's changed a lot I used to only answer
questions from viewers and those were
all my videos and I kind of got a little
bored of doing the same thing over and
over and over
over again even though it's helping
people so I did fewer of those and
started adding different kinds of videos
in and and I I might be a strange
example because I do have like all of a
sudden a video that's a vlog you know
something personal nothing to do with
business i go on disney trips every year
and then I i vlog it and that's on my
channel you know I just did a video of
me playing league of legends while
answering reader questions and that was
a test and I put that up I didn't I
didn't notify subscribers but it's a
public video and it's a test to see see
if I want to keep doing it see how much
fun I had doing it it was actually hard
to play a game and talk business it's
like splitting migraine too but you
should always want to be ticking
experiments and try new things whatever
you're curious about you want to put
that on your channel and I think the
danger a lot of people come into is they
make certain kinds of videos or they're
in a certain kind of business that keep
doing the same thing over and over and
over and over again and the more you
keep doing that the more people come to
expect you to keep doing that and then
you you build a box for yourself and as
entrepreneurs you hate being boxed in
you know we just we don't like being
boxed in the that's who we are as
creatures we want to keep doing other
things and so you've built yourself that
box but if you continue to experiment
and try new things to introduce new
things to your audience and you'll take
them with you and it doesn't seem like a
sudden crazy change and the longer you
wait to make that change the bigger the
gap it's going to be in the harder it's
going to be to take that leap so i would
say continue to experiment keep trying
new things and as you are curious about
something you bring your audience with
you would you do something that's
completely off in left field like if you
were doing business and then I don't
know do you have any like hobbies that
are completely out left field that
wouldn't work with your channel 11 I
mean so I'm a dancer I do salsa dancing
I'm going to salsa dancing company um
Toronto dance salsa is a name it's been
on the channel a lot I film out of the
studio now like all my videos and art on
the believe all anymore they're on there
at Toronto dance salsa I've made videos
explaining the difference between salsa
and merengue
bachata and kizomba um it's I would like
if it was something that I was really
interested in learning and teaching then
i would i would put it as part of the
same thing and I and it might be a more
limited audience but it would be more
deeply connected to what I'm all about
and those are the guys who are going to
buy your courses and your t-shirts and
your gear and when you have brain deals
are going to support you to who really
feel like they know you so I'm a big
believer in bringing things together
that's what makes you different because
they could get you know business advice
anywhere they can get crafting advice
anywhere there's a lot of people who are
doing what you're doing but does not
there's no there's only one you and so
for you to be different you have to beat
you and bring that to the things that
you're doing and so if you're just
playing like everybody else you know you
don't want to be for people watching you
don't want to be a Lindsay junior and
doing everything like Lindsay like yeah
it's what for her but you're not her you
gotta be you right like take some of the
things that work for her and then make
it your own and maybe that all is also
injecting dancing or swimming or
woodworking into it and that's that
attracts its own audience so if I felt
the creative need to want to go and
explore those things than I would but
i'm sad when you can't we can't expand
because you're so worried about what
what your audience is going to expect
and I know it's like sometimes all ball
trial can do filming set up or I'll try
new lighting or I'll wear my hair
differently or something like that you
know sometimes you get comments like oh
you look better with you know with this
hair or that hair or you need more
makeup or that's too much makeup or you
know you'll get like you know crazy
totally unrelated comments and stuff
like that well I'm the longer you stay
doing the same thing the more you're
going to get that and then the more
frustrated and you're going to be in
having to move away from it and I think
we do this in our lives too I went to a
salsa party that I was hosting and for
whatever reason I decided to dress up
like usually salsa is pretty informal
you were in t-shirts and jeans kind of
thing but I went like I have my vast
suit tie looking sharp everybody's like
let's see
asian like why are you so dressed up
what happened is it Nina's birthday
isn't your anniversary what's going on
like no I just felt like doing something
different and I think like we're just
creatures of habit and we keep doing the
same thing over and over and over and
over and over again and that can get
Superboy especially for entrepreneurs
who are creative people you want to do
things that are an extension of your
creativity and the more you make
decisions based on what you what people
expect you to do the less happy you're
going to be with what you are actually
doing and so for me the answer is
constant tinkering constant changing
constant evolving and I bring my
audience with me so it is not a massive
shock when they see something new or
different on the channel yeah it's a
good advice um cool do you see your
videos as a tool or your goal is it
video as a tool for you to do something
else or is your goal to make videos I'll
I honestly and this may seem completely
counterintuitive I do see them more it's
a tool because I don't want to stake
everything I have on a social media
platform and YouTube is a social media
platform um I do love doing videos but
it's not like if YouTube went away
tomorrow which we awful I'm not going to
be broke I have enough other revenue
streams and other things I'm working on
that um that I would be fine so I look
at it as kind of like a pie that sliced
up it's like part of the pie it's a part
I really enjoy and I love doing video
content YouTube is kind of a part of
that high um but yeah I don't consider
my goal I never would want to consider
my goal being on somebody else's
platform where somebody else pulls the
strings if that makes sense you know I I
know if I consider myself a youtuber as
much as an artist who uses YouTube and
uses a blog and uses um you know
workshops here and there you know as
part of like the whole picture I guess I
mean I love being on YouTube but I
wouldn't say that it's you know it's the
end all and be all because you don't
know if it's going to be here in like
five years yeah I love what you said it
but I'm an artist who just uses youtube
I consider myself
artists who just uses you 22 I can't
paint anywhere close to you don't want
to see my think my six-year-old can
paint better than me but I think for any
entrepreneur you are also an artist you
are using your creativity to bring it
into your business and and for me it's
the same thing to echo Lindsay's point
my goal is impact I want to reach people
I want to make a difference in people's
lives and YouTube is a a great way to do
it because it has huge reach and it also
lines up well with what I am good at you
know I I don't I don't want to write as
much as i would rather answer question
on video so when you can match up your
skills with the platform that can help
you do really well that's youtube for me
and if if something comes out that's
video that's way better like maybe
snapchat takes over YouTube or you know
mu tube comes along I'll move the mood
to Monica you move too because Lou to
get my goal is impact wherever I can
have an impact that's where I'm going to
be and if it's not youtube is mu tube
that i'll then i'll be on mu 2 yeah i'm
not super i'm very grateful for you to
super appreciative of the opportunities
that it's given me but it's not the goal
to make youtube videos um a dream a
dream adrian i don't know i hope i
pronounced it ok I shock mahou you
you're always upbeat she loves you
because you're always upbeat how do you
how do you stay upbeat actually we were
talking before that people think she's
Canadian I'm Canadian we need to have
people in general so how do you see
upbeat Lindsay what do you think um well
it's there's a couple things I mean I'm
not unlike everybody I'm not always a
beat but I have a radio background and
the first thing you're taught in radio
is before you turn on the microphone you
smile and people can hear that smile in
your voice and it makes you a lot more
engaging and friendly and somebody
somebody's gonna want to listen to
because you don't want to listen to
somebody that's kind of sour puss and
down in the dumps all the time you want
to listen to somebody who's going to
make you feel better about yourself and
in a smiling friendly voice will do that
and I find the more you talk with a
smile the more you actually feel happier
and so it just kind of feeds the Beast
again it makes you it makes you more
positive and feel more
positive but I also get to do what I
love so it's hard to be cranky when
you're painting or your crafting you're
creating and sharing what you love so
it's kind of twofold there I think and
if I have having a grouchy day as soon
as i get my studio and i start creating
and I start smiling and talking then it
does improve my mood and I feel better
but I will also say that sleep I am a
big believer in sleep diet and exercise
and I get eight hours of sleep at night
77 have 28 hours um I get up and I move
and I you know I could exercise more
heaven knows I mean we probably all
could and I eat a vegetarian so ate up
completely plant-based diet and I think
those things are very important to how
your mood and well-being so I get to
make art all day so yeah that's pretty
happy happy juice right happy juice I
love it happy juice yeah I don't know
that I'm as upbeat as Lindsay is it that
that's a hard the high scale to you of
the match but I agree if you're doing
work that you love not every day is
amazing and and you know over the top
awesome but if you can find work that
you can get lost in for me is probably
why I love dancing too because you can
forget about everything that's going on
and just dance and feel the music and
you know you get lost in your world so
if you can find that lever helping
entrepreneurs evil wake up and drive to
a job that they hate so it's really hard
to be happy when you come home when
you're spending eight hours they owe
your most productive time during the day
your most when you have the most energy
during the day doing something that you
hate yes cave is writing in I operate
under the belief that the idea is more
important than the marketing behind it
to what extent is is true do I need to
be very active in marketing my business
or YouTube channel this is ah this is a
very good one because I was just
thinking about that exact same question
today and there's like a couple
different versions of the 8020 rule and
one is but you should say like you spend
twenty percent time creating the content
you shouldn't spend eighty percent of
the time marketing but there's also the
8020 rule
we're twenty percent of the work will
get you eighty percent of the way which
is kind of what I subscribe to it's like
I could spend a week on one video I
could make the video and then spend the
rest of the week promoting it or I could
make I could make you know seven videos
and spend very little time promoting it
but every video is kind of promoting
every other video feed the beast again
because like I put out a new video then
suggested video shows you all these
other videos and you know it kind of
like us is helped from filling prophecy
and I think gets me further than if I
just did one video and spent all day for
a week on social media saying hey watch
this hey watch this hey this video's
cool watch this and you know spamming
people and um or sending out my
e-newsletters I only send out like
emails when I've got something important
to say but I post to my blog every day
and that does go out to all my email
subscribers so they're gay I think they
would much rather get a brand new
project it's fun to do that is not
trying to make them you'll watch the
same thing over and over again I think
that gets me further than trying to you
know spend four times as much time that
I did making the video just to promote
it so that's why my personal feeling is
making more content is better than
making more marketing but then again
i've also been doing it long enough
where i have enough of an audience so
that i don't have to spend as much try
and promoting and marketing it but
that's my opinion i left here Evans a
theory on this uh this is a great
question and one that I mean I wrestle
with two sometimes but I always come
down on the side of the content the
content is what matters I think of a
store when we made a video about 50 cent
and my team made the video and spent you
know eight hours researching it and
putting it together and then I looked at
is like uh it's not good enough like it
didn't pass the filter I was okay it was
good but not good enough and so that I
then spent more time making it better
and it ended up being something that I
was proud of releasing and when I got
released somehow it got to him and he
shared it so he tweeted he put it in his
blog he shared it on his facebook those
three places and the video exploded
would 50 cent have shared it if we
didn't put that extra little bit of work
in to make it better maybe but maybe not
and what I found is the stuff that is
really good like the stuff that
you come alive and stuff that if you can
really spend the time on the quality of
the content those videos take off much
more like you there are some videos that
when you watch you you instalike it and
you instachat and you want to tell
people well go check out this video it
really made a difference to me somehow
whether it's inspirational or something
crafty anything like made an impact on
you somehow those those videos that have
the ability to move somebody will get
the virality that you want much more
than marketing the people and say hey
please watch my video and so the
challenge for everybody is looking at is
your content actually good and that is a
sucky question asked because you feel
like your content is good but nobody's
really sharing it you have a hard core
audience I need okay what else can i do
to share with a who can I market who can
I tweet to let them know who don't have
to write to to get them on board we're
really the highest leverage tool that I
found is just make better stuff that if
people like it they want to insta share
it with their friends instalike it out
of the playlist tell people about it you
make something that that's good your
content will take off and so if I had to
pick where it's in my time it would
absolutely be into making a content
versus marketing the content but you
always get like me too i still get the
cotton market my videos better who do I
you know how can I reach out to people
and every time I try to interrupt myself
and say you know what just put all my
energy into making better videos and it
will take off and it has yeah and the
more you make the better you get so it's
self fulfilling prophecy I mean I look
back and I always think my first 200
videos are just crap you know it's like
but the more you do the better you get
and the more comfortable you get in
front of the camera and the more it's
hard to be yourself in front of the
camera and it takes a while to get there
I mean you listen my first videos I
sound so shy you know just cuz it takes
a while to be yourself in front of a
camera and to share it with the world so
you know its quantity breeds quality and
it's you know it's true I think you got
you got to give yourself a chance to
learn what you're doing and get good at
it before you should even
probably bother the marketing of it it
took me seven hundred videos before I
wasn't absolutely embarrassed by myself
embarrassed embarrassed I could not
watch my own video that's like more
videos and most people have on their
channel before i was in just seven
hundred videos if i was it not in
barrett's you know and then 1,300 videos
until i was inspired by one of my own
but like I watching man mmm that's good
like I'm actually getting decent here
1300 videos rather like the Lindsay's
example of like working 11 months and
not seeing any results and then finally
getting something are you willing to put
in seven hundred videos or 1,300 videos
work it just shows that I'm not
naturally talented you're persistent I
don't know what a gentleman the first
things I'd to do with my agent when when
I signed up was I had to tell my story
and and I had to do this like 25 30
minute video but my story and I had to
do it 30 40 times uh cuz it's just not
not good enough no I'm not good enough
fixes not good enough and sometimes to
be three times in the same day record in
the morning Senate them get feedback
afternoon feedback even recorded again
it's just over and over and over and
over and practicing and getting better I
forget the initial question but I got
down on that story Oh a say it takes ten
with ten thousand hours to master a
skill I mean it's true there's no
shortcuts you have to put the time in
and it being another interesting thing
about like how to channels if you're
making tutorials there's no saying
what's going to be popular you could
spend all week on a video thinking this
is a trendy topic it's going to be
popular people are going to pin it and
love it and it just does ho-hum and then
there could be something you were
inspired about and you recorded it in
eight minutes and uploaded it in its
like I've this this video on making
European style paper beads and it's
crazy popular and it was ramin grades I
spent days perfecting the technique but
when I actually recorded it was in one
take and it took eight minutes and that
is one of my most popular videos and I
think when you're on a schedule of
releasing every day you have better
chances of something really um
you create something and just law of
odds you have something you better
chance of creating something that is
going to go crazy there's going to be
just the ticket just what somebody wants
to see and the right person season
shares it and then it becomes a very you
know popular video especially with how
to when there's so many people searching
for specific topics that the more is
better for your channel yeah and I think
it takes the time to find your voice to
delay this point of being comfortable in
front of the camera but then to take it
the next step and be yourself and take
some risks on the camera because if you
watch Lindsay's channel you can learn
how to do something that 100 of the
people probably done in videos too and
you can maybe even get the same result
to learn how to put these bees in a
certain order like you can learn it but
you want to watch Lindsay do it because
she does it in her way and she's more
fun or just like the vibe or there's a
lesson attached to it you like the
presentation style whatever it is it
takes a while of practice for you just
to get used to what your what your voice
is going to be and at the start you just
you copy other people like you see how
Lindsay does i do it like her you see
how 10 shores as you do it like ham and
then and that's okay that's okay like it
gives you a benchmark but you won't have
the success you really want until you
branch off to pull from these people to
make you the best version of yourself
instead of trying to be the next whoever
like be the first you instead of the
next somebody else and it does come with
a lot of practice yeah and I never
really watched youtube before i started
my channel i always thought it was kind
of like a no man's land i'm like i don't
even know they just let anybody put
videos up there i don't know if i want
to see what people are putting up there
cuz like just seemed a little scary so i
never i didn't even watch youtube i
invented everything in my in my channel
I didn't you know I didn't subside it'd
subscribe to anybody I didn't know what
it meant you know I just you know
watching it on my and I think a lot of
my my viewers watch it right on my blog
and that's probably they probably never
even come to my youtube channel so I
didn't really have that expectation of I
should be like Hank green or I should be
like jenna marbles or iJustine or any of
those um youtube stars at the time
because I just know they were I didn't I
didn't watch I was in a YouTube fan when
I started my channel so i think it was a
little easier cuz i didn't have those
shoes to fill and I didn't feel like I
had to act like a
anybody other than myself it gets harder
now because people try to be outrageous
or try to be just like somebody else
it's got a stick and it's tough because
you know they're they're growing up
comparing themselves and comparing their
channel to these successful channels and
I think comparison is the thief of joy
it's a it's a establishing the
comparison is a thief of joy and if
you're just starting out and you're
comparing you're beginning to someone
else's middle or somebody else's end
it's not fair it's not fair to yourself
you know you just need to you need to
get used to being in front of the camera
and get comfortable with it and give
yourself a shot there's a great clip of
50 cent talking about how he's trying to
roll roll be a role model and bring in
people under him as a producer now and
all these people were sending him demo
tapes of them and they all sound like
little Wayne and you saying yeah it's
like it sounds like little Wayne like if
I didn't know that I wasn't him i would
have thought it was him you guys did an
amazing job of sounding like little
wayne but we already have a little Wayne
I know what little Wayne jr. I don't
want to sign in the guy who sounds
exactly little Wayne you gotta you got
to put your own work on it you gotta you
can model a little Wayne but you got to
figure out what your style is going to
be and so it's the same with any art
youtube was an hour painting as an art
sculpting you know making statues and
are just doing it the same thing same
way everybody else is doing it is not
going to get you success you want you
gotta find the artist in you and bring
that to the craft recruiting that's
absolutely true question I hope those
poppies are new tutorial there's a lot
of comments about the poppies behind you
is out of tutorial yes its oils we're
going to do it tonight I gotta just edit
the video and upload it but it shouldn't
take too long I'm keeping it real time
just because and that's funny because
like with my channel a lot of people
complain if I time-lapse things they
want like the long form content so yeah
I just got to put my clips together and
upload it and we'll have it up there
tonight for you I love it maybe last
question since we've got we're already
over time my question was meant to ask
if personal appearances are part of your
world or in your comfort zone versus
youtube videos so how much how important
is personal appearance for you
you in the videos that you're making I
guess you said like you put on your face
and you go and do your thing how much
does that matter for you ah um I
definitely wear more makeup if I'm going
to be on camera I'm not comfortable
going on camera without makeup on and so
like if it's just a video showing my
hands obviously I wouldn't bother
putting makeup on but I'm trying to get
on my face on camera a lot more now um
like I've mentioned earlier I just shot
a classic craftsy and I really enjoyed
being on camera and being able to talk
to the lens and talk you know engage
that way but I I don't feel comfortable
doing that without makeup on but you
know I'll go pick up my kids from you
know softball practice without makeup on
I don't however want to go in the
building and see other parents without
my makeup on which is kind of crazy but
you know I don't put on like a face of
makeup to go to the beach or anything
like that it um I don't you know I could
wear my pajamas to the grocery store or
anything I mean there's a certain i've
got a certain level of you know comfort
i put a little makeup on to go to the
grocery store and you know I don't wear
my pajamas on public but um but yeah I
definitely I don't feel comfortable on
camera on youtube without my makeup on
yeah you know I think it's a different
standard maybe for men I'd have to never
wear makeup I don't have much hair to
really have to worry about I I think I
care a lot less than I used to before
when I had meetings I would always be in
a suit in a tie and a shirt and now i'm
wearing usually something brand it could
be a tu hoodie I used to always shake
before I went on camera now it doesn't
matter like whatever I'm actually living
if I'm like full on beard I'll just go
out and shoot that video as it is there
are still some standards / I like even
this like it's framed right you don't
see the rest of what's going on um I
always try to wear something branded
hoodie t-shirt whatever so there are
some I think it's more my standards and
worrying too much about other people and
what they're thinking um so I don't know
how much that helps but I've cared less
and less and less as time is going on
about the reactions of what other people
think about what i'm wearing or how I
look there still is still there it
doesn't like go away completely
but I'm just carrying less and less and
less the more you have confidence in
yourself i think the less you care about
what other people think of you yeah i do
agree to that extent like I don't dress
up usually you know because a lot of
times I mean paint and stuff so I need
to not worry about what I'm wearing and
getting paint on it but um I personally
feel a lot more comfortable like if I am
if my face is on camera to have tough
some makeup on I'll kind of cringe if I
go back and look there there are a few
videos where I just didn't I just didn't
have time or feel like it putting my
putting makeup on and I cringe at those
or even even older videos where I don't
have very much makeup on I still kind of
like oh I wish I wish I did a little
something there you know what I mean it
maybe it's the artist part where it's
like I want it to look a certain way um
I don't know I I think it's also maybe a
little bit more difficult as a woman on
YouTube but you're competing with um
honestly competing because I believe
we're all in this together but when you
get so many like you know 20 year old
youtubers are just gorgeous without any
makeup on you know and you're kinda like
oh my god I'm 40 I need to cover this up
a little bit you know thank you
something here this is chris little
crazy but um you know I think that's
maybe part of it I don't know it's
probably a terrible message of young
women of the world do not listen to
anything I just said please I think you
can also use clothing or makeup for
yourself right like I will I will wear
this my believe hoodie even if I'm not
gonna go on and do a show because it
makes me feel that it's like I feel like
I'm Batman and putting it on my outfit
is my Batman outfit Here I am ready to
take on the world it's like different
than pajamas so it doesn't doesn't have
to only be further people can be for you
to feel better about yourself give you
confidence you're ready to go and shoot
this video or have this meeting or just
have a productive day like I could put
this on and just I feel like I'm ready
to do something important just by
putting on the hoodie and so that like
even if my fingernails get too long
sometimes just like cutting my
fingernails I feel like I'm ready to be
productive not that anybody would ever
comment about my fingernails it's for me
but like taking care of yourself and
being happy with what
you look like makes a difference oh yeah
when I would I first started in radio um
I remember getting first few jobs even
though it's radio and you can't see I
would still dress up and i would put
makeup on because i felt more confident
and I felt you know like let's give me
an awesome show you know and you know
just get you know you look good you you
sound good because you're smiling you
feel good because you're smiling and it
does it does resonate I know I feel
different if I'm if I turn that camera
on and I don't have makeup on I'm going
to feel a lot different I'm not gonna
feels confident they call it won't put
some courage your pocket you know put on
your lipstick or whatever and you know
go take up on the world or whatever but
you know it does it does a psychological
have some sort of psychological impact I
guess really like that you sound it
because you're smiling I like that I'm
gonna use it I like that now I'm going
to try to invite up before getting on a
call ever just starts smiling I like it
um cool Lindsay thank you so much i know
we went over really appreciate your time
i want to quickly touch on the craftsy
course that you just launched and how
people can find out about it and then
also where people can check out your
channel and learn more about what great
things you're up to sure I post daily
over on the frugal craft or YouTube
channel if you just this a link in the
video description but if you just go to
youtube and type in the frugal crafter I
think it's youtube.com / user / The
Frugal crafter um the most recent video
I have up is actually a promo for that
crafty class and if you click the link
in that video description it'll get you
a fifty percent off discount and it's a
mixed media class so I think people
think of mixed media as it just happens
and it's some magic and either you have
the magic or you don't have the magic
but I show the principles and how you
can build up a painting layer by layer
to create that interest and to
communicate your ideas on your canvas so
you don't feel like you have that views
on your shoulder it's art is just like
business your show up you do the work
and it happens and I kind of show you
this devastate process of creating those
layers and making your artwork really
look interesting and come alive so it's
a I think it's a great class it was a
lot of fun to make and it's packed with
content so if you like mixed media
please consider checking that out and
otherwise I post free
le tutorials on my youtube channel and
on my blog if you want more like photos
of the individual photos you can follow
me and that's the frugal crafter
wordpress com and i'm on different
social media networks and and whatnot
and you can get to any of those places
you can get there from here yeah you can
just click on my channel a million bucks
there's a Maine accent for you I love it
I love it cool Lindsay thank you so much
your time to love the energy I super
appreciate it I really enjoyed learning
more about your story too and all the
valley of the entrepreneurs thank you
guys so much for watching as well and
check out this is Channel that's it bye
thanks Evan